Secretary of State Anthony blinken is
traveling to the Middle East this
weekend as the U.S monitors escalating
violence in the region a day after
Israeli forces killed nine Palestinians
in a West Bank raid a Palestinian gunman
killed seven people near a Jewish house
of worship in East Jerusalem Friday and
hours after the Israeli military
announced its boosting forces in the
West Bank two more men were shot and
wounded in East Jerusalem today Rainey
inocencio is in London with the latest
on this Ramy good morning good morning
Jeff and in just the past few hours more
details on that attack just this morning
it was a 13 year old Palestinian boy who
shot a father and son on the street both
are alive in moderate to serious
condition that boy is in custody and
just last night the deadliest attack in
Israel since 2008.
so much sirens in Jerusalem Friday night
gave way to silence on the street these
Jewish residents gunned down by a
Palestinian man who police described as
a terrorist the victims leaving this
synagogue in the occupied East Jerusalem
area of Nevada after Sabbath prayers the
road still stained red as government
officials rushed to the area newly sworn
in prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu and
the controversial far-right minister of
internal security itamar Ben kavir has
enraged Israelis chanted death to
terrorists police shot and killed the
gunman his white car riddled with bullet
holes
but in Gaza
exuberant Palestinians smiled and
celebrated some passing out sweets to
people clapping in cars
spokesman for terror group Hamas says
the attack in Jerusalem is a normal
reaction to Israel's crimes against our
Palestinian people another saying the
deaths in Israel are a source of Pride
and that Revenge came as soon as
possible that retribution coming just
one day after Israeli forces killed nine
Palestinians in the West Bank
as tensions escalate prime minister
Netanyahu says Israel's actions in
response to last night's attack have
already been decided and urged people
not to take the law into their own hands
and Israel's cabinet will hold an
emergency meeting called for this
evening the hard right Orthodox
government can't do or say much more
until Sabbath ends at dusk the worry
here is more copycat attacks like that
13 year old boy just this morning this
return of Tit for Tat Bloodshed in early
and deadly challenge for Israel's new
government Dana
Remy thank you